Alleluia Christ is risen
Christ is risen Alleluia Christ is risen
oh no no one more time always three
Alleluia Christ is risen
welcome that it's great to have you here
on Easter Sunday
I miss the hats and the white gloves of
my youth in the south
I missed the bonnets and the white
patent leather shoes all those great
things but it is great to see at least
one hat today and it takes me back to a
warm place our guides to Easter today
are ambiguous ones st. Luke writes that
on the first day of the week at early
dawn the women came to the tomb taking
the spices that they had prepared the
women named later in Luke's Easter story
as Mary Joanna and Mary Magdalene and
others that are unnamed seem to be lots
of Mary's going around that these are
uncertain guards to the resurrection
because well they weren't planning on a
resurrection when they came to the tomb
that morning they were coming to a
funeral and their spices gave them away
so I want you to think this Easter
morning what do those spices mean in the
ancient world when everything had fallen
apart still you could bring spices where
I grew up in West Texas when everything
fell apart you would bring a casserole
it was hard to think of an occasion even
dire and shocking events for which a
casserole was not an appropriate
response after all we said people have
to eat in the same way and long ago
Jerusalem dead bodies had to be spiced
no matter how beloved or remarkable the
person who had died no matter how awful
the circumstances of their death it was
only proper to bring spices to scent and
preserve the body it was what grieving
people did for someone they loved but
those spices they were a sure sign that
you were grieving and you did not expect
that grief to end
the women weren't rooting against the
resurrection don't don't take it there
they more than anyone wanted him to rise
but they saw him die on the cross that
Friday and they knew from bitter
lifelong experience that this was the
way the world was the good die young and
the evil prosper those are the rules and
the spices were assigned that they
believed in those rules though they
wanted to believe Jesus and all the
wonderful things he said still the world
grinds on and as we hear from each other
entirely too often you got to be
realistic but when they got to the
garden the tomb was open which it
shouldn't have been and inside there was
no body to be perfumed and two strange
men appeared which i think is always a
little scary and asked the women these
grieving women some very unsympathetic
questions why do you look for the living
amongst the dead he is not here he has
been raised don't you remember what he
said that he would be betrayed and
crucified but would be raised why are
you looking for the living amongst the
dead why are you here in the graveyard
with your spices and I think the women
with their jars of myrrh and aloes
whatever it was I think they look down
at their hands at that moment as though
the spices had suddenly appeared from
nowhere spices
what spices we were making tabbouleh
we were just in the neighborhood on a
beautiful Easter morning in New Haven
Connecticut we come like the women I
think to the tomb we know what Jesus
said we know he said he would suffer and
die and rise again in three days but I
wonder if we have our own spices tucked
away we want to believe what he said not
just about dying and rising but the
whole package of what he said the part
about the poor and the lowly being
lifted up and the high and the mighty
being cast down that's a good part and
the part about the merciful and the poor
and the peacemakers being blessed by God
that's great
we want to believe it we want to believe
a kingdom of justice and peace is coming
like the women we've seen what with our
own eyes how the world treats the
innocent and the dreamers we want to
believe rising from the dead that might
be a step too far I think we all have
our own spices tucked away signs that we
are still grieving and unsure that in
this terrible world in many ways that
there is hope of life and resurrection
we want all the wonderful things Jesus
said to be true but we hedge our bets
our commitments are with death our
spices are the reverse of Pascal's wager
we have them just in case God doesn't
come through Marcus Borg has said the
dominant values of our world are all
things of death affluence personal
achievement can I say that again
appearance power competition consumption
individualism violence all these things
that lead us away from the kingdom Jesus
described a kingdom where weakness is
strength he said where profit can only
be made by giving away everything you
have where people are loved for their
wounds rather than their
parents and their money we succumb to
often to the inevitabilities of this
world of life stealing realities
sometimes we even give in and accept
that this world of competition and power
and isolation is all there is we forget
that God loved this world and all of us
so much that God became one of us that
each human life your life my life was
worth dying for
we want to believe and yet on this
Easter morning we find ourselves at the
open door of the tomb and the men say
why do you look for the living amongst
the dead and we feel something down in
our pockets
yeah we heard Jesus say look at the
lilies of the field he said
and don't worry for tomorrow but we have
our spices to keep us company in this
dying world and we worry and our parents
worry for us and so we bring spices like
an elite education which for some is a
guarantee of security more powerful and
more real than any of God's promises
that we don't have to live like those
poor people or perhaps even see them
those are our spices
perhaps I do believe what Jesus said
about loving my enemies but still I want
to hold back it's so much fun to have
enemies
to get together with my friends and talk
about how stupid and obnoxious they are
whether that's an Old Campus on an ell
campus suite or in my office or in the
US Congress I want to believe that all
human beings are my brothers and sisters
but I hold on to my spices and well
maybe even one more
I believe that the story of Jesus in my
heart I believe that it's a life given
even life-saving story and that when
it's invited I should offer it to other
people who are suffering but that's just
too religious and no one likes religious
people we could keep going through the
whole spice rack as many as you're
willing to imagine all the ways we live
our lives as though Jesus was still in
the tomb and never rose all the ways we
live as though the mighty will not be
cast down the lowly lifted up all the
ways we live as though the world will
always be as it is unjust corrupt
pointless and violent but the Jesus I
know from the scriptures he wouldn't
hold our spices against us he knows
we've got them if Jesus were to meet us
in the garden on Easter morning and saw
us trying to hide our spices behind our
backs he would laugh and he would hold
out his hands until we like guilty
schoolchildren coughed up every jar
Jesus knows we have to live in a world
that thinks God's good news is a fairy
tale in a world that's learned from
terror and wars on terror from greed
fueled economic meltdowns from
idealistic Crusades that turned into
Crusades a world that has learned that
we should be hard-nosed realists and not
give our hearts away to any dreams but
the empty tomb is not a dream even the
disciples who doubted the women came to
believe that at least once something
impossible did happen and that one
impossible thing changed everything they
remember what he said that the human one
the child of God the Lamb of God would
have to suffer and die because death
does rule the world and yet having been
crushed by the worst the world had to
give he would be pulled out of that dark
tomb by the hand
of God and would rise to push death off
the throne and rein in mercy and joy
forever we come to the tomb bearing our
spices faintly hoping that we will not
find a bloody corpse but pretty well
convinced that's what we will find but
he is not there
he is risen an old friend told me about
a man he knew in his church who was an
unlikely Christian he's a world-renowned
biochemist who was very quiet about his
faith but solid and in an unguarded
moment the man told my friend that he
struggled with belief especially in
miracles and resurrection and crazy
things like that but once at an
especially tough time in his life he
resolved to do a simple thing for his
faith a simple daily thing and no one
knew he did it except his wife and his
children he resolved that every morning
when he rolled out of bed and his feet
hit the floor he would remember to sing
to himself he said he didn't always
remember but some days it made all the
difference about the day his day went in
the lab or teaching and her
administration that indeed Jesus Christ
was risen that day my friend said he saw
the man at a memorial service for a
church member who had been killed in the
World Trade Center on September 11th
2001 and with a very sad look on his
face he said the man gently clasped him
by the shoulder and hummed in his ear
and said even today and again years
later when the man's mother died my
friend saw him in the hospital and
through his tears again the man hummed
and said especially today finally the
man's wife told him that after her
husband had died a difficult death in
the hospital she and his children
clasped each other's hands together
resurrection means a fundamental
reorientation of the universe away from
death and towards life in its fullness
it means a fundamental reorientation of
our lives away from meaninglessness and
a cold universe where suffering is
always just suffering two universe that
is in spite of so much of our experience
powerfully tending towards Grace and joy
and healing it is a faith we live in to
some with a radical leap some with a
daily song it is a faith that will never
be popular in this world and that others
will always question but over time we
find that we don't need to hedge our
bets we don't need our spices because
over and over again in our lives and in
the lives of our brothers and sisters we
have seen Christ rise and one by one we
can let go of our little jars our
security blankets are comforting
pessimism and look up and see God's
kingdom of justice and peace coming to
earth with the risen Christ at its head
hallelujah Christ is risen Alleluia
Christ is risen
Alleluia Christ is risen